in times of the coronavirus this is what
Istanbul sounds like at night from their
slaps and on the streets people are
cheering and applauding Turkey's health
care workers we want them to know that
we're supporting them may God help their
work have you seen that alone may God
protect them without them we'd all be
lost here take the solid shell the song
that makes us proud to see our health
care workers putting aside their own
needs at a time when our society needs
them most musician's challenge was a
music show cool and real total Pharaoh
and never not letting us down and for
all your great efforts we thank you very
very much
Istanbul is hardly recognizable these
days at the world-famous Sultan Ahmed
mosque workers are disinfecting the
squares that are usually filled by
thousands of tourists
in fact all mass gatherings in the
countries nearly 90-thousand mosques
have been suspended some faithful now
hold their prayers in parks keeping
their distance turkey is just at the
beginning of what might grow into a
health crisis the country's first
coronavirus death was confirmed on
Tuesday since then the number of cases
has been rising Istanbul is a city of
sixteen million and the empty streets
are clear sign that many people here are
taking the threat of infection seriously
schools paps gyms have been closed and
public transport limited and the city's
mayor has ordered workers in full
protective gear to disinfect buses and
subway trains on a regular basis
they're [ __ ] together we will get
through this our country our city can be
an example for the world an example in
how to keep coronavirus cases and
fatalities low my fellow citizens of
Istanbul we do have difficult days ahead
of us but they will pass and everything
will be fine eventually don't lose hope
don't lose hope it is the same message
that people send to Turkey's health care
workers at night in Istanbul
[Applause]